-Performing the title track to
her new album,
"The Devil I Know,"
please welcome Ashley McBryde!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ A little outside
of Elizabeth town ♪
♪ There's a little bar
where I'd sit down ♪
♪ And trade a couple country
songs for Kentucky bourbon ♪
♪ A little ol' gal
in the middle of the night ♪
♪ Learnin' how to love
and learnin' how to fight ♪
♪ And learnin' how to like
my brand of hurtin' ♪
♪ Hell, there's hell everywhere
I go ♪
♪ I'm just sticking with
the devil I know ♪
♪♪
♪ Mama says
get my ass to church ♪
♪ Daddy says
get my ass to work ♪
♪ Doctor says I gotta give up on
these smokes ♪
♪ Everybody's got something
to say ♪
♪ About how I gotta change
my ways ♪
♪ But I got something to say of
my own ♪
♪ Hell, there's hell everywhere
I go ♪
♪ I'm just sticking with
the devil I know ♪
♪ I love somebody everybody
loves ♪
♪ And he's in love with
my messed up ♪
♪ Most folks can't see my soul
through the smoke ♪
♪ And we're suitcase marks
on a hardwood floor ♪
♪ Flippin' the bird,
slammin' the door ♪
♪ And peelin' out and turning
'round and coming home ♪
♪ Hell, there's hell everywhere
I go ♪
♪ I'm just sticking with
the devil I know ♪
♪ Mama says
get my ass to church ♪
♪ Daddy says
get my ass to work ♪
♪ Doctor says I gotta give up on
these smokes ♪
♪ Everybody's got something
to say ♪
♪ About how I gotta change
my ways ♪
♪ But I got something to say of
my own ♪
♪ There's higher roads
than I rode ♪
♪ Better choices than I chose ♪
♪ I'm just sticking with
the devil I know ♪
♪♪
♪ Hey, hey ♪
♪ Whoa-oh, oh-oh-oh ♪
♪ Mama says
get my ass to church ♪
♪ Daddy says
get my ass to work ♪
♪ Doctor says I gotta give up on
these smokes ♪
♪ Everybody's got something
to say ♪
♪ About how I gotta change
my ways ♪
♪ But I got something to say of
my own ♪
♪ Hell, there's hell everywhere
I go ♪
♪ I'm just sticking with
the devil I know ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]